in one word just one word what would you
say your professional style is jovial
I'm here in the Meatpacking District of
Manhattan with Josh Miller who's the one
of the cofounders of branch which is a
new social media tool and I'm not going
to be able to explain this properly
because I don't understand it so why
don't you tell me yeah thanks for having
me branch is a way to talk to each other
about the things you care about so very
simply it's a way to have a conversation
with your friends just like a dinner
table conversation type of conversation
you have in a bar or coffee shop so and
when you were showing me a good earlier
it really it really is much more
intimate so if I started a branch about
the forbes 30 under 30 I would I would
you know start it and I might invite the
15 people that we called out in the
various categories and then we would
have a conversation among ourselves and
if that would be public people could
view it but they would not be allowed to
comment and then I could take that and
embed that on my personal site is that
essentially the idea yeah essentially my
co-founders and I Jim Ryan Harris
realized that a lot of our friends were
really opinionated about the things we
cared about where there were sports or
music or movies and we wanted to talk
about those things but you know some of
the online ways you some of the ways
expressed ideas online blogging or
tweeting it was like a weird format it
wasn't really approachable and we
thought well how did we share opinion
the real world then it was around a
dinner table or in a coffee shop having
a conversation with a couple people that
we trust so we've tried to replicate
that online but then added this element
where you know you're talking to your
friends but anyone that might be
interested can go and read that
conversation so as you said you can
tweet that out you can share that
conversation on facebook you can put it
on your website of your publication so
the conversation it can go wherever it
wants but it stays between the people
that you want to talk to so you're
joining a few other famous college
dropouts and starting a company you were
you start you know I'm on a leave of
absence my mom would kill me oh sorry
mom not a drop out on a leave of absence
Josh Miller but you were you were
between your junior and senior year at
Princeton one of your other co-founders
is also an undergraduate and other one
was at school as a graduate student yep
I guess he finished his degree yeah but
the other two are you taking it some
time off to do this yep we were going to
be as seniors right before we started
the company and what
sort of the courage to do that I mean
that that takes a lot you know you know
you're literally nine months away from
getting an Ivy League degree and you say
my window of opportunity is just closing
somebody else is gonna come up with this
great idea or did you get encouragement
from somebody else yeah so it's funny
I've always been the type of person has
a ton of ideas and always was working on
projects and this was the first time
where I was just working on this kind of
cool project after hours with Hirsch one
of my co-founders and someone that we we
had met at that our co-working space
Dogpatch lab said you know you should
talk to this guy Jonah Peretti we had no
idea who Jonah was and we kind of looked
him up on Wikipedia said would you
rather meet this guy and we met went to
meet with Jonah and at the time the idea
was just sketches on a piece of paper
and we showed it to him and explain the
adisa wow this is this is really cool
you know I don't know if you're thinking
about doing this full time but if you if
you decide to work on it I want to work
with you and that's when her should I
and generate were just like man maybe
this is something we should kind of
think deeply about doing and you know
one thing I realized is you know I
wasn't the best student I didn't have
the best grades yet I found myself at
8am as soon as I woke up I popped out of
bed and was excited to work and I was
working till 5am and I realized that if
I'm that passionate about what we're
working on that's probably what I should
spend my time on you've gotten a number
of really interesting people and
interesting range of people that are
already using branching and just so
everybody knows that their branches
still in the sort of a closed beta if
you want to join up you can go to their
site branch calm and ask to be invited
but you've you've got some people you
just tell us a little bit some of the
use cases that you were describing yeah
it's been really surprising because I'm
fairly boring and like kind of the you
know politics conversations about the
kind of stuff going on Afghanistan and
so we have some of that general former
general stanley mcchrystal was in a
branch the other day that was on Fast
Company the New York hopefully not
criticizing Obama no no he said he was
he was on point and New York Times use
branch to talk about the election but
any other an inspection we've people
talking about their favorite reality TV
shows and we have Dutch librarians
talking about their you know their trade
and what's going on in their industry
and we have people swapping videos and
travel tips and it's been really cool to
see kind of the Brett's breadth of the
things that people want to talk about so
that's been the coolest part of it so
far to see now folks like the New York
Times and general McChrystal and you
know
people in other parts of the world
talking about the things that matter to
them you have some pretty impressive
backers through the to the site both
sort of financial and supporters you
want to talk a little bit obvious Corp
the Twitter guys and what their
involvement is and how that's helped you
move along sure yeah so like I said
Jonah Jonah Peretti was kind of the
first person that came on board to help
us out and then in jan in december of
2011 we got introduced to evan williams
Jason Goldman and biz stone at the
obvious corporation who previously
started twitter and blogger and we
actually moved that to San Francisco to
work closely with them on the project
and they've been and Jason golden
actually moved back to work with us here
and they've just an amazing resource not
only financially but just advice about
kind of strategy and what to build and
how you can encourage people share their
ideas online because I mean blogging and
tweeting have completely changed the way
we express ourselves and that's what we
hope to do as well and it's just been
invaluable to have anecdotes and helpful
advice from them we only have time
really for two more questions so I'm
going to actually one sort of odd ball
one and one straight board not bad so
the difference the the startup culture i
mean we could be sitting in San
Francisco that would probably look the
same probably raining also uh but what
do we feel the differences between
working in san francisco in new york and
since you did go to the trouble of
moving out there and moving back maybe
if you give people some insight into
that well so that's a that's a really
long that'd be really long answer but
one in ago i'll give is two doors down
on either side their investment bankers
with eight monitors doing financial
trading and there and there's a fashion
studio and on a Sunday when we're here
working late there are people rolling
down you know you know closed down the
hallway and then you see the screens
going crazy with the numbers and
everyone that's here is very passionate
and ambitious and excited about what
they're doing and that really rubs off
on you especially when it's from
different industries so I think the pace
of the city and kind of again the
breadth of the people on the things they
care about when we're talking about
branch we don't want you just to talk
about tech and startup culture so
services we can feel a bit like a mill
town in that way everybody's sort of
right and that's what makes it amazing
and that's what makes it a perfect place
for a lot of tech companies but for us
where we want to be a tool that lets
people talk about the things that matter
them it made sense to be in you know
when the greatest cities of the world
where there's so much going on in so
many different industries and types of
people like I mean I know it's cliche
hopping on the subway and hearing
multiple languages and is amazing so
just in three words if you're going to
give some advice to somebody who's
sitting in their dorm room and has an
idea project and they're they're
thinking about it what would this sort
of three words be three words wow 105 do
what makes you excited